- Today, someone said
nice meeting you, Jim.
There are much worse things to be known as
than Jim Halpert from the Office, boosh.
That's kind of one of these.
When I first got the
Office, my friends and I
went to a bar, we're
talking like season one,
and my friends, we
couldn't get in the bar,
and my friends just said, just go up
and say you're from the
Office, and I said okay,
so I went up to this bouncer and I said,
I'm, I'm an actor, I'm
the guy on the Office.
And he goes I don't care.
I don't think I can successfully
really incorporate all
that is Chris Pratt.
There's a whole lot of charm there.
Any kids movie, definitely the Lion King,
Frozen, cried in that,
at Olaf of all people.
I'm 92 years old, I don't even
know how to turn on my phone.
That's not true, I do know
how to turn on my phone,
but I don't know how
to do email or Twitter.
Does that mean that
you get to like wrestle
an actual creature to the ground?
I've had a great experience with Uber,
but there have been one or two times
where I feel like I'm in Speed Racer,
which is exciting and terrifying.
No, I don't think I've watched
any episodes since the show wrapped.
We always used to get together
to watch the episodes,
so there's nothing that
fun as getting together
with your whole cast, and like having
your arms around each other,
eating a couple cheese plates.
I don't know if I can recreate that.
Yeah, as an adult, you're like
chicken nuggets and fries,
I mean I'm not going to eat like a whole
bland colored meal, and then
you order for your daughter,
and I've had my daughter say like
I don't want chicken nuggets,
and the waitress will come by,
and I'll be like, she
loves chicken nuggets,
and then they're gone because I eat them.